thanks for my son yes so you've been
watching at home that you've been shot
at the telly you've been emailing you've
been tweeting you've been letting us
know what you think Joe what time and
from you gave us here with me we've been
looking at reaction over the last couple
of hours it's been really busy traffic
hazard it yeah absolutely expectations
Fred miliband were very low he was very
much the underdog 34 points behind in
the ratings it was all to play for and
it's been a very interesting night well
let's take a look at some of the tweets
first off David Cameron from Emily Perry
Paxman shoots he scores David winces he
doesn't know what to do it's over he's
done battle for number ten Paxman gets
the very heart of Cameron's
vulnerability and impression that he is
weak against the strong and strong
against the week and it was a really
tough start wasn't it from Paxman that
really was reflected on social media
yeah that's right and of course it's
this massive question about
vulnerability weak strong and fairness
and inequality that Labour going to
press on again and again next one
initial impression was that he was
teaching would rather be somewhere else
but then the PM did want to avoid the TV
Jules altogether that's from Jeremy clip
let's look at some more let's bring them
down Stefan this is a bit like a
nightmare tutorial and Davis shown up
with a slightly ropey SA and that was
really the theme wasn't it but then as
we go on to the economy Dan Hodges
noticeable how much more confident
Cameron is when the issues the economy
Cameron truly in his element in this
format really looking confident
comfortable will Miliband be as strong
here and it didn't really pick up didn't
it as the as the questionnaire answer
went on that's right and the economy is
no doubt strength for both the
Conservatives and Cameron himself is
where their competency lies then we went
into the studio audience we had the
chats both of them Miliband Robert code
says gotta say all joking aside Miliband
is winning me over a bit always psalm is
a bit of a doof but now not so sure
george eaton Miliband biting back at
Paxman a better look than frozen Cameron
and it was a slightly different tone at
the start of the the Paxman Miliband
exchange wasn't quite as confrontational
some would say how do you think they did
I think that Ed Miliband certainly
overperformed against the expectations I
think probably on balance he came out he
came at best i think he also benefited
from going second and so came out very
very strongly and didn't have the the
sort of slower
slightly dela start litter the Cameron
had I suppose Melbourne have been warmed
up a bit by the audience though evony
Miliband wrong foot spaetzle on
immigration agrees the Labour government
got policy wrong seizes control of the
interview convincing and then this great
line which gotta gotta laugh in the
audience didn't it and Twitter and while
you're important Jeremy but not that
important Miliband goes for the knockout
Labour's new campaign slogan to be am I
bothered battle for number ten the end
of the day who do you think got the
upper hand I think all things considered
probably Miliband just by bit the
question is though will this make any
difference to the polls what will the
average voter think back at home indeed
we shall see we're gonna be getting more
reaction in the next hour back to Adam